question came up actually from dr steve
bagley um which i have quite an interest
in myself which is
what programming language would you
start with so you know for a child 8 10
something like that where'd you start
i think one of the options is certainly
scratch which was designed as something
that was meant for young kids and it
seems to be extremely successful you can
do interesting things you can animate
stuff you can have games that kids can
play they can build on each other's work
there's an ecosystem there and i think
in many ways for young kids let's make
up a number 8 10 something like that i
think that would work really well
my experience with scratch which i used
briefly with google's app inventor when
it was a thing some years ago
the problem from a programmer's
standpoint is that you run out at some
point scratch is great for certain kinds
of things and then you run into a wall
something that just can't do or is so
incredibly complicated that you wouldn't
possibly want to do it at that point i
think you have to shift to mainstream
kinds of programming languages if i were
going to do that today i would probably
teach
kids python because that's the best
combination in my mind of easy to learn
because it is an easy language it
doesn't have any limitations you keep
going with it it has an enormous
ecosystem of useful programs libraries
modules packages so that pretty much
anything that somebody has wanted to do
you could do with python
and somebody's done
a package that will make it your job
easier so i think that would be the next
step and then after that who knows at
that point you know enough about
programming that any other language you
could just pick it up good practice
stuff so if you're learning a musical
instrument you want kind of like instant
gratification you want to be able to do
something and accomplish something
quickly and one thing that scratch is
great for is like it's got all the
built-in icons and
i think that's still a possibility with
python
it's harder i i think you've hit on
something that's very important that
instant gratification kid sees a video
game thinks i would like to build my own
version of a video game with scratch you
can do that if you're going to do it in
something like let's call it python it's
just harder because getting all of the
things that make things move or then
interact with people and so on
that's not what the language was meant
for there are certain aspects the
language like the library mechanism
maybe somebody's done it for you but
fundamentally no you don't get the
gratification as quickly unless you get
your enjoyment by manipulating text in
which case it's great
i suppose my thing is because i'm not a
programmer people have heard the story
before about how i failed miserably
after a bit of basic but
what you know you've written something
in something like python can you
distribute it as a kid i'm thinking or
is that
i think the answer is not really you
just have to distribute the python
program you have to hope that the
recipient has a python
interpreter compiler uh on site which
probably they do or alternately you can
probably put it on one of the websites
that support python
and there's a bunch of those the one
that i've been using lately in classes
is
it's an online version of jupiter
notebooks
google's collab which i think is
extremely useful and you can take people
who aren't programmers
and get them started doing python by
dropping them into an environment which
has some of the stuff loaded and then
they can start adding their own bells
and whistles to it without
they can slide into programming without
realizing that that's what they're doing
and and so i think that environment has
worked pretty well for me with people
who are basically not very technical and
certainly not going to be computer
programmers but would profit from being
able to use computing in their
environments in their day-to-day life
one thing to say about the scratch thing
is are you are you getting transferable
skills there and versus like python
where perhaps i think perhaps you are
obviously i think
i i haven't used scratch enough to know
whether it's really transferable some of
the ideas do transfer the idea of a loop
for example the idea perhaps of a
function call
the idea of variables that take on
different values as program progresses
uh the idea of how you make things move
all of those things are transferable
skills that would go into another
language although
the syntax as soon as you move into a
conventional language is utterly
unrelated because you're not sticking
together these little boxes
um
so i think then the same thing might
happen with python where you learn how
to program to to figure out algorithms
data structures whatever
in
python and then
you might run out of you know you might
need something that was more robust
that ran faster
that could be encapsulated into a single
executable that we hand to somebody
rather than source code
and for those things you need to move to
a can let's call it a conventional
programming language c c plus plus java
the skills that you learned in python
that and in fact probably many of the
actual bits and pieces of the code would
transfer relatively straightforwardly
into some other programming language so
at that point you can you know you've
done something you built watermelons to
a prototype let's say in python then you
can do something more substantial in
more
you know more industrialized in a
mainstream language let's call it c
do you think most people do
sort of move through different language
or experiment with different things or
do people find a language learn it and
stick with it is that
i think it depends very much on what
your environment is if you're a
professional programmer you probably
have a collection of make up a number
half a dozen languages which you are
comfortable in and you're probably using
one at any or two at any given point
because that's what your employer uses
or in some way that's what your source
of income depends on and then something
changes and you move to another language
and it probably takes you a brief period
like an hour or a day or something to
get up to speed or to recall what you
used to know in the other language or
you go to some place completely
different and they're using a language
you've never tried before let's say rust
and you say gotta learn rust okay and if
you're if you've done
n programming language the n plus first
language is usually not very hard to get
off the ground and then it probably
takes some while to get to be a real
solid pro at it but yeah i think the the
average programmer has a repertoire of
things they're comfortable in a
somewhere between half a dozen and a
dozen languages and then there are
people who collect languages because
they're fun i think they want to explore
them i have a friend alan donovan who
i've worked with on the go book he's one
of these guys who just oh there's a new
language let's try it see what happens
and i i'm not one of those people yeah
this stuff but i admire people who can
do that so as i'm guessing there's sort
of two sizes of learning the idea of
programming and then learning the actual
nuts and bolts of the language itself
yeah right
how would you go about choosing the
language for a particular task that you
need to program
ah how do you choose the language well
it's like i suggested it may be imposed
on you because that's what you do i mean
you said you're teaching see it
nottingham because that's sort of
imposed maybe you're part of the
imposition but that that's what you do
um
if it's a free choice i would think that
in many cases that's an opportunity to
learn a new language i have something to
do
and i could learn
pick a new language rust haskell
whatever uh by trying this thing i want
to do in this new language but that's
back to sean's question earlier about
instant gratification if it takes you
too long to do it in this new language
then the tendency is to heck with that i
want to get the thing done and so i'll
use the language i'm comfortable with so
just a delicate balance between
wanting to do the language but also
wanting to get the program to do
whatever it is it's supposed to do
and so i beyond that i don't know but i
guess i would probably pick language
where i want to know something more
about it for some reason for some people
that would be economic like i'm a
consultant i could make more money if i
knew how to program in
node
something like that and so i better
learn that if your income stream depends
on something then
you better to focus on what you already
know and have
control over and understanding of the
trade-offs
and i guess there comes a point where
you realize that it's the wrong language
for the job when you have to make that
call between i've invested this time in
writing this in go
but now i need unmanaged memory do i
translate it to rust or c and how do you
find that balance i honestly don't know
i guess that's the sort of thing that
comes with more experience certainly
than i have this kind of thing
talk about long in the tooth we're
replaying our lost youth or something
like that
but why would you use it today and i
think the answer is that
it's an example of what's the right tool
for a job and then once you've factored
it you can just do these steps to
completely calculate the private key